luckily, I grew up in a very educated community. You know,
30 minutes away from MIT, Harvard, you know, all of the Ivy Leagues in Boston.
and I think that's, that speaks a lot to
kids and their value, not value system, but their manners and so forth.
>> Sure.
>> So, I don't remember
getting teased too much. I'm sure I did and how much of
that I have sort of put under the surface and forgotten about.
>> Uh-huh.
>> but I, I don't, I have a tougher
time even today when I'm in an inner city environment
where my, the people surrounding me don't have the same
etiquette and don't have the same education, the same exposure.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And that's really where I struggle more
than where I grew up, in a suburb of Boston.
>> well to get a bit more of that sort of educated thought and idea I want you
to tell us you know, as a medical condition of, of dwarfism what is,
what do you know is the cause of
shorter stature and in particular, in your case,
what is the what is the cause of, of this? Well, remember, there are over 200
different types of dwarfism, achondroplasia being the most common. So,
if you were to meet another little person in your
life, most likely they'll have achondroplasia. So I can only
really speak to achondroplasia. it is a dominant gene. It is
also a mutation. So, what that means is, an individual
can have achondroplasia for two reasons. One would be their
parents have it and it's been inherited as it was
with my children. The other would be it's a genetic mutation
which is a complete unexplained event which is what
it was for me. I, I am the only
little person in my family. My little brother is
six three. and my parents, my grandfather was a
genealogist. So, you can imagine he spent a lot
of time looking into this. and I am the
only dwarf in my family origin. But, I then
went on to meet my husband who also has achondroplasia,
we got married, and we have three children. I gave birth to two of them and
I flew to Moscow for the third one,
to adopt from an orphanage. who also has achondroplasia
but clearly not from me or my husband. she, from all we know, which is really
not much is a mutation as well, her
parents were average height. And I suspect, in Russia
it, it's a lot harder to be a little person. I have
two children that I gave birth to, one in August of 1992, the other in November
of 1997. The gene was discovered in 1994 or five. So, that
meant that my pregnancies were very, very different. In 1992,
the only diagnostic tool that they could use was ultrasound and again,
they were looking at the femur in the fetus and they could not measure that
accurately until I was 24 weeks pregnant. So, at that time, they told me, and I
was actually being seen by the gentleman that
wrote the birth, the growth charts for fetuses
at UCSF and he was the one reading
my film, my, my measurements from the ultrasound.
>> Mm-hm, mm-hm.
>> And he said, Jenny, this is a tough one. He said, that
femur is in the 7th percentile. And
typically if we're looking at a hetero-zygote.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Meaning that the embryo, fetus, has gotten
the gene from one of you, that femur's going to
be over the 10th percentile. Right around between
the 10th and the 20th or 30th or something.
>> Mm-hm.
>> and you're coming in at the 7th and that makes us very
concerned that perhaps you're carrying a homo-zygote. And
a homo-zygote, what that means on, in, in
lay terms is a double dominant and in
achondroplasia they have found that to be lethal. The
baby is born and lives no more than a week. Typically, more a matter of hours
without life support. So, it was a really
tough call. So, we went ahead and, and went
with what we thought was right and Alex
was born and obviously he's still with us, he's
20 years old. So, he must be a hetero-zygote
although he has had a lot of medical issues.
>> hm.
>> jump ahead five years later and in between that, by
the way, I'd flew to Moscow to adopt a second child.
>> hm.
>> I'm pregnant again with our now 15 year
old and I have an amniocentesis at ten weeks.
And within a week, I get a phone call
from a genetic counselor at Bailey University in Texas telling
me, you have a hetero-zygote, 100% certainty. So, you can
imagine the difference in the stress involved around both pregnancies.
>> Absolutely.
>> I knew what my odds were when I was
ten years old and babysitting and knew that I wanted
to have children and I wanted to be a teacher.
I, did that influence my selection of mates? Did I
say to myself oh, I'd better not find
a, I'd better not fall in love with another
achondroplastic because we have a 25% chance of having
a homo-zygote? Absolutely not. Do I ache for my
boys, who will most likely by mere fact
of numbers, will wind up with achondroplastic women and
this will be on the table? Do I ache
for them, before they're are even, you know, really
dating?
>> Mm hmm.
>> Absolutely, I ache for them.